GE STAHL, ONE
>> ROSSI ON GREAT BACK CHECK.
RUST, OFFENSE, ROSSA
CA THERE.
ANTHEN IF THEY GET
AN TO GO THE THE
SE FOTHE YOUNGSTE
IN A PRETTY GOOD STOP
RITHE TO MANAGE IT WHEN  ON THE
>> MISSTHE SHORT-HANDED ON THAT
PORPTHE JARVIS
SEBACKFOR RUWIDO.
THPENALTKILL EARLY TENDERS, WHE
CAUP -- TAKE A LOOK AT
ROTR TO TURN IT TO
THCENTER, THE BATTLE BETWEEN ER
PIMOCANADIAND
CA MADE DUE ON THEIR
CH AT
MAANOTHER GREAT
>> HE IS TO 10 FEET OUT.
TA A LOOK HITS HIM UP TWO, THE
THCOATTACK.
HE IN.
BA AGSTEVEN LAWRENCE
THE POINT.
LO ATBOYLE.
SHIEHIS MAN JUST FOR OVER THE
THICE.
TH A TENT, THERE'S A
REFIRES, H
SC CROSBY CROSBY
SCORE A LOT OF LONG-
SH HEIN THE FIRST CENTER DRIVE
AND IT JUST A BEAUTIFIRST, NONE
TH DENSEL.
GE THSHOT OFF.
HE WILOOK UP.
ROD WITH THE PASS.
THHE IS THIRD PERIOD,
3-2 LEAD.
THEYGODROP PASS TO DEANGELOWITH
CATO DO